great weather outside i should say yeah
but we miss when ted's not in studio but
we know he's got to be on some rides out
there at boca park ted have you met a
lot of nice people
yeah there's a lot of people out here
kirsten uh and it's getting packed as we
speak so we want to let you know a
little bit more about this pumpkin patch
we're going to bring in mike thomas
first of all mike thomas i want to thank
you for having the easiest name in the
world so we could pronounce that easy
and please take the mask off
oh i'm just going to i'm kept
with halloweentown thanks for having us
here tell us i mean this is huge i drive
by this all the time but what can we
find in here that everybody can do
there's something for everybody there's
young rides for the young kids there's
games that the adults can remember when
they were children there's cotton candy
there's carnival fair and food there's
great opportunities for pictures and
it's probably the single best selection
of pumpkins in las vegas i'll agree on
that and this isn't the only location
how many locations are there because
there's people all around the valley
watching us right now absolutely we've
got another location at rainbow and warm
springs and then another one at
silverado ranch and las vegas boulevard
that's great now which one has the
margaritas
that one okay
we also have to village across the
street so that works too michael thank
you so much i appreciate it we'll see
you again uh in the five o'clock hour
right thank you sir appreciate it